en esta ocasión quiero hablarles acerca
del concepto de aceleración lo
escribimos aquí aceleración
y seguramente ustedes ya están
familiarizados con esto escribamos su
definición la aceleración es el cambio
de velocidad
velocidad durante un tiempo dado
durante un tiempo
quizá el ejemplo más típico si es que a
ustedes les interesan los autos es que
las revistas deportivas o en los eventos
donde hay carreras de automóviles les
darán las cantidades de aceleración como
parte de las estadísticas de estos autos
de carreras encontrarán algo así como no
sé voy a inventar de una marca va a ser
un porsche porsche 911 que va de 0 a 60
millas por hora millas por hora que
normalmente esto se abrevia mph millas
por hora en tres segundos
aunque esta primera parte que nos dan
esto de 0 a 60 millas por hora es la
rapidez o la velocidad y recordemos que
si es la velocidad se tiene que indicar
la dirección bueno cuál va a ser la
aceleración acá bueno acabamos de ver la
definición el cambio de velocidad
durante un tiempo
entonces la aceleración como aquí
estamos hablando de velocidad y la
velocidad es un vector pues la
aceleración también va a ser un vector y
nos dicen que es el cambio de velocidad
y aquí usamos la delta para indicar qué
es el cambio
este triangulito es la delta y nos
indica el cambio en la velocidad y la
velocidad es un vector durante el tiempo
que también es el cambio en el tiempo
podríamos ponerle una delta t
pero también lo podemos manejar sin la
delta dejándola te solita que esto nos
va a facilitar la anotación de las
fórmulas vamos a cambiar de color para
darle variedad y bueno el cambio en la
velocidad nos dicen que esto va de 0 a
60 millas por hora la velocidad final es
y la velocidad inicial es de 0 entonces
para calcular el cambio en la velocidad
restó la velocidad inicial de la
velocidad final en este caso 60 menos
ser velocidad final menos velocidad
inicial y ese es el cambio o la
diferencia en velocidad y todo esto son
millas por hora y como es velocidad
vector vamos a tener que indicar una
dirección en este caso vamos a suponer
que va hacia la derecha entonces es
millas por hora a la derecha
muy bien y ahora cuál es el cambio en el
tiempo pues el cambio en el tiempo viene
siendo tres segundos lo escribimos acá
tres segundos así que esto nos viene
dando o es igual a menos 60 menos 0 de
60 60 entre 13 de 20 y voy a escribir
las unidades de manera diferente millas
por hora
expresada como fracción y todo esto está
dividido entre segundo y bueno la
notación de la aceleración es bastante
extraña esto qué significa significa que
este auto va a acelerar cada segundo va
a acelerar su cambio en velocidad va a
ser de 20 millas por hora cada segundo
este auto va a aumentar su velocidad en
20 millas por hora y no olvidemos
escribir a la derecha ya que la
velocidad es un vector y siempre tenemos
que poner la dirección cuando hablamos
de vectores bueno tenemos aquí las
unidades millas por hora entre segundo y
yo puedo expresar estas unidades esta
parte del tiempo de esta otra forma voy
a reescribir lo aquí abajo esto es igual
a 20 millas
/ y esto lo puedo expresar como ahora
por segundo lo escribimos aquí abajo
ahora por segundo como es que puedo
hacer esto bueno si yo aquí al segundo
lo divido entre uno no lo voy a estar
afectando pero lo que me ayude a hacer
esto es que si yo multiplico esto de
aquí arriba por esto de aquí abajo y
estos dos de enmedio entonces me van a
quedar millas por 1 que quedan millas y
esto millas por 1 me queda en el
numerador entre esto de aquí abajo horas
por segundo pues me van a quedar estas
unidades millas por hora por segundo que
siguen siendo complicadas pero bueno
vamos a seguir trabajando esto un
poquito más vamos a simplificarlo me
queda esto millas por hora por segundo y
vamos a englobar esta parte de las
unidades en otra unidad aunque no es
obligatorio se puede dejar así pero
vamos a simplificar un poquito más lo
que quiero hacer aquí es multiplicar
esto por algo que me permita quitar las
horas de aquí abajo entonces voy a
multiplicarlo por algo que tenga horas
en el numerador
y pues que tengas segundos en el
denominador bueno porque lo voy a
multiplicar o que cuántos segundos tiene
una hora pues va a tener 3600 ya que una
hora tiene 60 minutos y cada minuto son
60 segundos 60 por 60 son 3600 así que
esto lo pongo en una hora hay 3.600
segundos o en un segundo hay un 3600
szabó de hora y ahora pues hacemos esta
multiplicación aquí se nos van las horas
con las horas y nos queda que esto es
igual a 20 entre 3.600 y las unidades
son millas
por segundo por segundo muy bien siguen
siendo complicadas las unidades pero
creo que es un poquito menos vamos a
simplificar la parte numérica quitamos
estos celos y dividimos numerador entre
2 y denominador entre 2 nos queda que es
igual a 1 180 bo de millas por segundo
al cuadrado millas por segundo al
cuadrado bueno este es el resultado esta
es la aceleración de este auto qué
significa esto
bueno una forma más clara de verlo es
que si ustedes se imaginan el
velocímetro que lo voy a tratar de
dibujar aquí más o menos cómo se vería
aquí está donde se mueve la aguja y aquí
están las marcas que indican la
velocidad
y aquí va a estar un 10 20 30 40 50
vamos a escribir lo bien que lo
escribimos y 60 aunque bueno esto
realmente no sería como el velocímetro
de un porsche sería como el velocímetro
pues de un auto normal común y corriente
y aquí está la aguja antes de encender
el auto esta aguja va a estar en cero
aquí está está en ser cuando transcurre
un segundo si es que nuestro auto tiene
una aceleración constante aunque
normalmente pues no va a ser así pero
pues imaginemos lo para dar claridad de
este ejemplo cuando transcurre un
segundo la aguja del velocímetro se va a
haber movido a la marca de 20 el auto va
a haber acelerado al pasar un segundo 20
millas 20 millas por hora en un segundo
pasa otro segundo y aquí mi aguja se va
a mover a la marca del 40 millas por
hora si pasa un tercer segundo ahora mi
aguja estará marcando 60 habrá aumentado
otras 20 millas por hora así que la
aguja estará ahora en la marca del 60